y como lo veníamos hablando con rosa
pérez más de vamos a entonces a analizar
lo que está pasando en francia de cara a
esta primera vuelta de las elecciones
que tienen lugar este domingo 10 de
abril y para ello entonces quiero
saludar a maría esther y es profesora de
ciencias políticas y relaciones
internacionales en la universidad
externado de colombia gracias mari por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 buenos días muchísimas gracias
muy buenos días mariposa entonces
empecemos contextualizando un poco a
nuestra audiencia internacional a cómo
llegan todos los candidatos a esta
primera vuelta de las elecciones que van
a tener lugar este domingo no en el
contexto internacional además de la
guerra para después ya poner punto por
punto y puntos específicos que queremos
analizar con usted mar y bueno raúl
primero lo creo que es importante decir
que estamos frente a una campaña
política bastante inédita y medida por
tres razones obviamente el contexto
internacional pero también la
consecutividad de las crisis primero el
cob y ahora la guerra segundo porque hay
un cierto desinterés por parte de los
franceses frente a esta campaña con un
riesgo de atención muy elevados
seguramente lo vamos a hablar y por fin
porque tenemos una extrema derecha que
nunca ha sido tan alta entonces tenemos
una campaña y medida por esas tres
razones y 12 candidatos con un trío de
cabeza que se está claramente
sumando la mayoría de los votos y tal y
como veíamos repasando la prensa hay
muchos medios que reprochan a emanuel
macrón haber participado precisamente de
dar fuerza a las ideas de extrema
derecha no pues un poco con también las
políticas que la he llevado a cabo como
la ley contra el separatismo la ley de
seguridad global la represión que se le
ha criticado pues a los movimientos
sociales se podría considerar que el
manuel macro no ha llevado a cabo pues
un gobierno de derechas
un gobierno de centroderecha diría yo
efectivamente hubo algunas posiciones
que incluso podían sorprender por parte
de un presidente que venía del seno del
partido socialista sus medidas
económicas claramente son de derecha e
incluso son difíciles de diferenciar de
unas propuestas de la derecha clásica
tradicional de república encabezada por
valérie pécresse en este momento
y en cuanto a lo social se puede decir
que está jugando sobre una tendencia
efectivamente tratando de
acercarse a un electorado un poquito más
de derecha que al inicio efectivamente
de su trayectoria política
marc y también le quería preguntar
después varias cosas primero porque es
una campaña atípica que está pasando y
porque también la abstención de los
franceses en lo que van a hacer estas
nuevas elecciones presidenciales además
según las últimas encuestas todo indica
a que esta segunda vuelta se va a
disputar entre la ultraderechista marine
lepén contra el candidato presidente
manuel macro porque vuelve digamos a
llegar y porque este auge como estamos
hablando más o menos con rosa pérez de
esta extrema derecha que está pasando
realmente dentro del electorado francés
dentro de la sociedad francesa
si sumamos los tres candidatos de
extrema derecha llegamos a un porcentaje
del 33 por ciento de intención de votos
hacia la extrema derecha lo cual es como
lo hemos dicho muy alto cuáles son los
factores que pueden explicar
esta esta subida o esta tendencia pues
tenemos un tema de fondo que es más
estructural una banalización y un
trabajo desde abolición del partido del
asombro nacional de marine le pen que
empieza a ver sus frutos y analizar
claramente esta candidata pero también
tenemos coyunturalmente para esta
campaña un efecto y riquísimo es decir
que finalmente a marín lópez le ha
servido bastante la campaña de eric de
muga en un primer momento la debilitad o
claramente además se siento se sintió
abandonada por parte de sus apoyos más
históricos incluido incluyendo su
sobrina valió maialen pende pero
finalmente la campaña tan radical con
unas salidas bastante
provoca antes y hasta hasta deplorables
dice mucho sobre el islam sobre los
refugiados ucranianos han permitido en
margen el open de centrarse finalmente
aparecer como menos radical y sobre todo
a poner en primer plano temas sociales y
sobre todo económicos y fue ella
finalmente que puso sobre la mesa uno de
los temas que realmente va a servir
decidido para esta campaña que es el
poder adquisitivo pasando en segundo
plano todos los temas que son relativos
a lo clásico de la extrema derecha
seguridad inmigración
desperdicio - radicar aunque realmente
sus posiciones siguen siendo las mismas
no ha cambiado sobre el fondo entonces
esta continuidad de la campaña de desde
abolida ción ha sido muy favorable a
mach en el pen
quisiera también añadir otro factor que
me parece importante son al menos uno
también aboga por la banalización de la
candidata porque siempre está poniendo
al mismo nivel en un pie de igualdad
alcan la toma con irak a nadal open al
ponerlos en un kit de igualdad al final
banaliza la presencia de la extrema
derecha en el debate público y tenemos
una implicación un riesgo muy grande si
ella llega a pasar en la segunda vuelta
sería que pudiera verse como la
alternativa
y la única a nivel macro haciendo desde
esta segunda vuelta a una especie de
referendo motivarán y precisamente como
veníamos comentando cómo puede afectar
la abstención tanto a la derecha como a
la izquierda como pues a la
centroderecha de macrón a la abstención
es un tema que realmente está en juego
en estas elecciones tenemos miedo
incluso que podemos llegar a los
porcentajes históricos de la elección de
2002 con un 28% qué pasa con la
abstención claramente cuando haya mucho
abstención en una elección siempre
afecta la el resultado final en la
medida en la cual son las categorías
sociales más populares menos politizadas
y los jóvenes que tienen a no ir a votar
y precisamente este tipo de sectores son
el electorado de los candidatos de la
extrema tanto derecha como izquierda en
mayor medida a marín lo pendientes de la
extensión podría ser desfavorable a
marín loop en los que van a ir a votar
son como usted lo dice en su
de prensa las categorías superiores y
por lo tanto es un electorado muy sólido
tanto de makoun aunque pues como se
podría analizar también con una alguna
matriz pero por ejemplo de valérie
pécresse claramente entonces esta
atención de categorías populares
agricultores jóvenes va a afectar
principalmente podría afectar
principalmente a manning lepén igual
todo está sobre la mesa todo puede pasar
vamos a ver qué va a pasar entonces este
domingo 10 de abril en la primera vuelta
de lo que sería en esta carrera
presidencial al palacio del elíseo en
francia para ver quién va a ser entonces
el nuevo presidente francés gracias
marido por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
muchas gracias a ustedes